for me if you want to talk about
building a parallel economy creating a
competitive Marketplace in the space of
ideas there's no better place than to
start right here because in the
education space Hillsdale has been that
disrupter I mean it's 178 years in that
space But in the last 20 years it is the
model if you don't like the way things
are you can sit there and complain about
it or you can go out and do something
build something different tug at the
country I subscribe to the theory that
we live in a constitutional republic so
brilliantly designed that every time the
pendulum swings a little too far the
gravity of the American people pull it
back and throughout history that's
happened the 60s gave us Reagan in the
80s right and I think we're at that
moment now where the pendulum is just
pulled to that maximum point in the
gravity of the American people will
bring it back there are some challenges
right we know them we just went through
a week of challenges and maybe a month
of election challenges I don't know when
election day became election month but
it is now
um but I want to start with the election
and I want to I'll come back and tell
you a little bit about my profession and
where we are
um there are a lot of positive signs and
all of the disappointment that I'm sure
many of you feel today right
um but the mission of this election was
to put a block at the Joe Biden
presidency in the Biden agenda and if
the Hops hold down which I think it will
buy two or three seats
um the Biden gender will be stopped dead
in his tracks for a couple years that
slows things down for Republicans to
figure out how they're supposed to win
elections in the 21st century and the
truth of the matter is Republicans are
running elections that are in the 1996
to 2008 strategy Zone and the Democrats
are fighting in 2040. they have we play
checkers and chess and they play
Battleship with nuclear-armed weapons
they have changed the rules of the game
and Republicans said good idea and then
they we don't play by the rules and I
think this election more than any other
has the potential to wake up the
Republican party to realize that if you
want to get on equal footing you got to
play by the rules of the game it's great
to be principal Ronald Reagan once said
but you never unilaterally disarm and
when Republicans dropped out of getting
into the absentee mail ballot game where
it's legal by the way I'm not suggesting
illegal activity if you give up you've
given the other side an advantage and
the way the other side has changed the
advantages you now can bring in ballots
three four days after election day and
you can cure them for seven days
afterwards they're still fixing balance
in in Nevada people can come in and fix
their ballot I know France it must be
laughing at us right now because they
get it done in a day but the rules have
changed the Republican mindset hasn't I
think this is the wake-up call for them
they did two elections where they were
convinced they could beat the absentee
ballot vote with Daya vote and they have
now failed two times in a row and I
think the truth of the matter is there's
a thing called in politics called Low
propensity voters that means someone who
will not vote unless you make it
absolutely easy for them if you have a
couch potato at home that is usually
what we call a low propensity voter they
will not get up and go to The Ballot Box
but if you give them a stamp and an
envelope and you drop off the ballot
application you deliver the ballot
application you come back when they get
the ballot and then you nag them until
they give it they eventually will vote
and that's what the Democrats do the
Democrats don't do much illegal they do
something's illegal but
um usually what they do is they run an
operation it's it's a it's a vote
counting operation if you were counting
customers you'd know how many customers
hadn't bought the thing that you wanted
you go out and get them and Market them
until they bought it that's what
Democrats do every day they go down to
the registrar office and find out who
are the people that got absentee ballots
who haven't voted that look blue and
then they go out every day and harangue
those people until they vote now there's
a big issue with that right you got to
wonder whether it's free will voting
anymore when that sort of pressure is
applied on you but that's all they're
doing the the elaborate ideas of
significant schemes the Democrats aren't
capable of pulling off a massive scheme
they tried it with Russia collusion it
didn't happen right it's not possible to
pull off a grandio scheme where multiple
machines do things they're doing
old-fashioned Tammany Hall Ballot Box
stuffing using absentee ballots and the
pandemic gave them that accelerant to go
out and change the rules and if
Republicans want to do it there's really
three simple things I wrote a column
this morning and I looked at how Ronald
Reagan reboot after losing the
convention to Gerald Ford in 76 and he
spent a four-year window and by the way
when that happened everyone around him
sounded like probably everyone you were
talking to in the last couple days the
election it's over Ronald no 69 year old
guy is going to run in 1980. it's not
happening good run be happy go home and
he's like no I'm not I feel the calling
of God I'm going to and he wrote this
amazing letter to one of his followers
saying sometimes failing is God's
greatest way of ensuring you eventually
be Victorious and I think right now as
you're sitting here thinking what Ronald
Reagan went out and did he realized a
couple things one I got to modify my
message it's a little too obtuse it's a
little too for the the top of the
intelligency of the conservative
movement it needs to be brought down to
the dinner table because politics is one
at the dinner table so all of a sudden
all of those ideas that he and Goldwater
talked about in 64 that gave rise to the
daisy child ad you know that sunk
Goldwater Ronald Reagan retooled them
and he said you know what my message is
going to be there's an evil empire and
we're going to defeat it it's that
simple an evil empire you don't want to
be like those guys you want to be
trapped behind the Iron Curtain and
we're going to win through a very simple
concept called peace through strength
simple dinner table Concepts Republicans
talk past too much of the independent
and everyday Americans who don't have
time to think through Paul Ryan's 500
deck
PowerPoint presentation right they need
it simple Kevin McCarthy put out a
really wonderful thing called the
commitment with America but it was
actually War and Peace for Republicans
it was 150 agenda items who has time to
read that Newt Gingrich had it down to
10 simple things and you knew what they
were Donald Trump had it down to one
simple thing I'm going to Build That
Wall right it's got to be simple
Republicans make this complex they
unilaterally disarm on an election front
where by the way they were complicit in
passing all those laws Pennsylvania
Republicans were in charge when you got
absentee mail ballot Michigan same thing
Wisconsin the same thing the Wisconsin
election commission which is probably
the worst and most corrupting
um idea ever created in election
politics in a state was created by a
republican Governor as a solution to
South being the Democrats prior cheating
he created an entity that created new
cheating and they changed the rules
it's a simple fix and while you're all
depressed and you say okay I understand
Republicans are a little off the Mark
here is what happened that you haven't
been told by the news media first off
Republicans won the popular vote this
election that hasn't happened in a very
long time they won the popular vote
53-47 the day after vote for congress
that's a big achievement Unfortunately
they want it really big in Florida and
not so much in Pennsylvania Michigan so
there has to be an adjustment going on
but when you can win the popular vote it
means America wants a change of course
now those same people who voted and I
don't don't ask me to explain why but
the same people who voted uh to put
Democrats back in office some who can't
even speak full sentences also said by a
70 margin this country's on the wrong
path now there's a little disconnect
there right on the wrong path but you
just put one of those guys in there
that's keeping us on the wrong path we
have to figure out why it's a pretty
simple reason when you get into
Pennsylvania we'll just use Dr Oz as
what I've interviewed over 100 people
since the election and I've tried to
drain the best ideas
um most of the experts I talked let me
say what happened with the enthusiasm of
the Trump movement is we created
national television stars Maga Heroes
but elections are one at the local level
right and you have to be able to appeal
to the local mores and issues and
there's two things about Keystone State
residents there's some Pennsylvania
people here right you know this right
yeah right that's right I was just
talking with you Pennsylvania is a
really proud of pennsylvanians they
don't like carpet baggers Dr Oz is a
carpetbagger secondly it's a very strong
staunch pro-life state in fact it's the
only Democratic state that continues to
send a pro-life Democrat to Senate if
you put up a Outsider who's waffling on
abortion inside a state you end up
losing the the the authenticity of your
candidate so a very simple adjustment a
different candidate maybe McCormick they
probably win that race and now we're not
talking about the end of uh of another
Democratic Senate so a little bit of
adjustment on candidates there's a lot
of stars in the Republican party but
making sure you match the Stars to the
races and the mores of the local race
get in the game on absentee ballots and
fix some of the messaging problems we
people want simple promises and they
want you to deliver on them and
Republicans had this obtuse message that
they dumped in the middle of August
which is not exactly time to get
messaging uh and it was just too dense
make it simple we know what we want to
do we're a freedom loving country we're
going to restore Freedom we're going to
get your budget down and we're going to
make sure that your kid doesn't get
indoctrinated by some bureaucrat who
thinks they're your child's parent
that's all they have to do and the
people who ran those races Brian Kemp
ran that way in Georgia uh Ron DeSantis
ran that way simply in Florida they won
by large margins those who waffled or
tried to fit in a 250 page uh campaign
platform you get lost in the in the mix
and so they failed to make the
connection
that you need to make with voters to to
win this race but there's a lot of
positive data here's something
interesting married men unmarried men
and married women all favored
Republicans for the first time since
Donald Trump's race in 2016. unmarried
women mostly under the age of 40 voted
for Democrats by a 72 percent margin so
Republicans are talking past one very
important demographic in America it's
fixable and abortion exacerbated that
because the Democrats were smart and got
abortion uh uh ballot initiatives and
five really critical States including
Michigan and so that brought their vote
out in a different way Republicans could
have done a parent's right thing heck
they had the legislature they didn't do
a parent's right initiative right that
would have brought Republicans out in
droves or made moms and dads rethink do
I really want to vote for a Democrat
that reminds me I got this kid issue
with my school that I want to deal with
they missed opportunities but these
adjustments on the dollar what Ronald
Reagan did from 76 to 77 to 80 and you
saw what happened in 1980 and if you
remember the way he simplified his
message that's what Republicans have to
do two or three simple messages stick to
it I believe the country is slightly
center right if you can connect with the
language and the Simplicity of what your
promise is I think this next election
will do real there are a lot of good
biorhythms in this election just not the
win at the top of the level they have to
adjust and so we'll see what happens I
wrote a column today with six ideas
we'll see if if the Republicans do that
but a lot of people think there's a
simple adjustment to getting back to
where I know you probably all want to be
all right so I really came here to talk
about what's wrong with my profession so
if you have the next three or four days
we can get the first chapter done but
it's not it's going to take longer than
that
um I get asked all the time how could it
be that we are now in a country
where a financial services company feels
bold enough to say I'm going to deduct
2500 out of your account without your
permission if I think you've shared
something on social media that's
disinformation that actually happened
two weeks ago fortunately they were
shamed out of it but how did we get to
that point how did we get to a point
that for two and a half years a
presidency was side railed by a story
that was never true not even remotely
true Russia people say boy John you must
have done a really it never was true it
wasn't that hard to disprove FBI agents
were saying it's not true it's not true
and yet for three years it was allowed
to sustain and torture this country and
stop a president from potentially being
successful a president you all voted for
some of you come from Missouri here
right I know I met a couple people from
Missouri earlier right yeah there yep
um you had a popularly elected governor
that was indicted and removed from
office on a charge that turned out to be
dreamed up by the victim and the
prosecutors knew it was false but they
proceeded with the indictment until they
could get him to resign and then they
dropped the indictment I just got
documents the other day that showed
literally the level of sophistication
that took the will of the people of
Missouri and stole it from them how does
that happen how did we get to this point
and the short answer is it goes back to
a meeting in the early of spring of 2001
shortly before 9 11. uh we had just been
through the hanging election of the
Florida election Bush V Gore Bush one
the Democrats weren't happy and George
Soros and people like him convened some
of the elitists in the party and said we
have to solve this and the uh the
diagnosis was Republicans have done a
great job over the last 20 years since
the rise of Reagan of owning the
narrative in America they had Direct
Mail Richard Vickery put stuff in your
mailbox every day and got a conservative
message to you and you liked it got talk
radio rush and Sean and Mark and all
those talk radio was a dominant for us
and they had Fox News and quite frankly
Democrats could not compete in any one
of those three mediums they tried with
MSNBC they tried with direct mail they
never could succeed to talk radio Al
gorsing was a disaster so they they they
knew there was a moment where the
communication channels were going to
flip and in these early meetings in the
spring of 2001 this is all reporting I
did about two years ago before I started
just the news they came to the
realization that Republicans owned the
narrative you own the narrative you own
the election now they had a couple of
interesting good bets first bet was they
had this idea that there was going to be
the Advent of digital communities and
that the Democrats should go there and
own them by the way that's what we now
call social media we didn't know what to
call it back then but there were going
to be these digital communities people
were going to band together find
like-minded people and talk to them all
day through their devices I was a good
bet they figured it out in Facebook and
Twitter and YouTube came along and the
Republicans got there if you remember
the 2008 race John McCain was going on
the trail and doing his uh Straight Talk
Express and Barack Obama was getting
Sharon Stone to give you a personal
birthday wish on your Facebook page I
know which one I'm going to take her
quicker it's not going to be John McCain
I can tell you that right now the
sophistication of immediately co-opting
uh social media to make a personal
message make Barack Obama personal to
you is how the 2008 race was created
they called it the digital tether that
was all invented in 2001 and there were
two or three premises that the uh that
the liberal Elites who had these
meetings as post-mortem settled on the
first was
if you own the narrative you can own the
action if you own the action you own the
election just think about how Donald
Trump got side railed to this thing they
owned a narrative that wasn't true they
got the action of a special prosecutor
and Donald Trump basically lost the
election in 2000. in 2020
64 percent of people still thought that
he had colluded with Russia even though
he had been cleared that's how powerful
owning The Narrative is